if you want to hear my ideas about the
meaning of midsummer then stick around
to the end of this video welcome back to
things you missed I'm not going to
attempt to fully explain every little
image in this movie because there's so
much packed into it and I'm not familiar
with the culture that it's based on so
in this video I'm just gonna tell you
what I did notice what connections I
made and what my interpretations are so
the movie starts with this painting of
the village divided up into four
sections spring summer fall in winter
this image establishes the cyclicals
eeems that we'll see throughout the
movie the cycle of seasons throughout
one year the cycle of life death
impregnation and rebirth and the actual
class system that the Communist --is the
Swedish American friend Pelle explains
that children under 18 are considered to
be in the spring section of their lives
spring is known for leaves starting to
grow in the trees so it goes along with
their idea of children growing up maybe
even hitting puberty and growing hair
ages 18 to 36 are considered to be
summer when the trees are at their
fullest our characters fall into this
age range and they're in their prime
during the movie the events take place
on Danny's birthday drawing attention to
the fact that we are supposed to notice
that they're in their prime there's even
talk at the beginning that the boyfriend
Christiaan could be wasting his time
with Danny they tell him that he could
be with that waitress right now and of
course the movie takes place in summer
I'm sure you didn't miss the title of
the movie midsummer ages 36 to 54 or
autumn and this is when the leaves start
to fall off the trees and they start to
decline this could be seen as when
adults start losing hair and reaching
the end of their reproductive fertility
ages 54 to 72 or winter which maybe
explains why the cultists are so upset
when Chris John's friend mark pees on
the dead tree because they see it as a
symbol for their own past elders when
Danny asked what happens after 72 he
gives her a cut-throat gesture I think
we see this happen in the ceremony on
the second day that they're there where
two of the oldest looking villagers
referred to as the ones lead the feast
and then sacrificed some blood on the
ruins of top of the cliff the American
characters are shocked by the diving
scene that follows another cycle we see
in the movie is the day/night cycle
Danny has a painting in her living room
of two moons in the night sky it
provides a contrast to their destination
in Sweden for the day's last twice as
long as the nights when they enter the
village they come through this big Sun
shaped structure and the platform at the
centre of the village has a Sun painted
it's the city that they come from seems
to be in the middle of winter so they go
from a winter with two moons to a summer
with two suns also when Christiaan is
eventually garbed in the colts
traditional clothing at the end of the
movie a sun and a moon can be seen on
his robes there were more symbols about
the circle of life like when they first
arrived and there's an older woman
chanting prayers and what I'm assuming
is Swedish there are not always
subtitles shown during these prayers but
this time there are and she says spirits
back to the dead whenever Danny drinks
that tea that gives her the drug trip
she sees grass growing on her feet an
image commonly associated with the idea
that the dead are taken back by nature
when the tourists get freaked out by the
cliff jumping scene one of the village
elders tries to calm the girl down by
explaining that life is a circle and
it's actually a great joy for them to
die and give up their spirits to the
upcoming newborns and I know I'm not
supposed to put my opinion but that guy
who broke his leg didn't look too joyful
I mean I could be wrong but in my
culture screaming and being agony is
typically not a sign of joy when Danny
and Christian talked about it afterwards
he says that it was shocking but the
tone of his voice says otherwise he
suggests that they keep an open mind and
try to acclimate to the culture from
this point on in the movie they
transitioned from spectators of the
rituals who participants becoming a part
of the ritual and taking on the
traditional clothing and eventually
Danny has even able to speak their
language during the dancing competition
as they become a part of the cult they
become a part of the cycle and one of
the women in Maya takes an interest
increased Gian Danny later becomes the
May Queen Maya may they could both be a
reference to the calendar month of May
where spring starts to become summer
Pelle explains that Maya was recently
approved for some ritual and it
basically means she's allowed to
reproduce because she too is going from
spring to summer and becoming an adult
pregnancy is focused on throughout the
movie in the very beginning Christian
and his friends are out at the
restaurants and one of his friends sees
their waitress walk away and says you
could be getting that girl pregnant
right now kind of a weird thing to say
if not for the circle of life metaphor
also the way that they're seated at the
table they're seated in an arc similar
to the way that the women are standing
around Christiana and Maya during the
impregnation ritual there's also a
picture frame above the table of a woman
bending over the shot is composed so
that only her breasts are in frame
another parallel to the ritual that's
the most literal reference to the
rebirth metaphor but there are also more
symbolic ones such as the women in the
commune dancing in a circle around this
phallic structure during the feast after
the big Dan
in competition an overhead shot shows a
food sculpture in the middle of the
table representing an unclothed woman
and in the next shot the phallic
structure is lined up over the body of
this woman there are some images from
the beginning of the movie before they
go to Sweden that come back later in the
movie above Danny's bed at her apartment
there's a picture of a bear kissing a
girl
Danny's boyfriend ends up inside of a
hollowed-out bear for the final ritual
of the movie in that room that Christian
is taken to so the older lady can ask
him to impregnate Maya there's an image
of a bear on fire on the wall
another foreshadowing of his fades
increased John's friend's apartment
there's also a similar foreshadowing he
has a framed picture of the Scarecrow
from The Wizard of Oz in that final
burning ritual there are people whose
corpses are stuffed with hay like a
human scarecrow also during that scene
at the apartment after Danny shows up
everyone kind of bails out besides her
in pal he seems genuinely interested in
her and I think he already knows that
she's fit to be the May Queen and
possibly join his family he tells her
I'm so happy you're coming then when the
whole group arrives at the commune the
village elder says were so happy to have
you only making eye contact with Danny
as he says when Pelle and Danny have the
one-on-one talk he again emphasizes his
pleasure that she came with he
challenges the idea that she's really
happy they'd increased June and tells
her the story of how his parents died
and the family was there for him Danny
and Christian become more and more
distant during this time which is
visually conveyed when he gives her the
birthday cake with the candle and
literally can't keep the flame between
them burning Pelle explains that the
family didn't bicker over what's theirs
and what's not we see this because the
babies are raised by the community not
just the parents when Danny looked
through the keyhole and sees her
boyfriend cheating on her a group of
several woman cry and suffer with her
providing a contrast to her crying on
her boyfriend's lap at the beginning of
the movie and Tim not really reactant
Christiana and his friend Josh bicker
over who gets to write the thesis paper
on this community but they recommend
that the to share the topic I think this
conversation that he'll has with Danny
helps me understand the character arc
that Danny goes through in the movie and
how the Colts helps her get there at the
beginning she's too emotionally
dependent on her boyfriend and she's
afraid that she leans on him too much
which is only worsened by her family
tragedy he's considering breaking up
with her because it's too much for him
then she's introduced to the family and
she sees how they have this community to
support each other Pelle gives her
thoughtful gifts and she becomes a part
of the family after winning the dance
competition and
the may clean at the end of the movie
they asked her to pick the next
sacrifice and she essentially becomes
the one to break up with Christiana and
become a permanent part of the family
when she chooses him now as far as the
actual room characters seen all over the
village go again I don't really know the
culture and I don't have a way of
translating them but here's what I was
able to figure out throughout the film
there are two characters that come up
over and over again first there's this R
shaped one which is sometimes seen and
rotated or flipped it's on the birthday
drawing that Danny receives at the top
of the cliff where the jumping ritual
takes place on Danny's robes and on the
clothes that Christian receives it can
also be seen on the doors to the room
where the impregnation ritual takes
place and I'm pretty sure it shows up in
more spots around the comment this is
the only symbol on the village that I
know the meaning of because one of the
cult members points to it in the book of
rune characters and says that it
represents grief it's obvious why it's
so often associated with Danny
the other one that appears a lot is this
hourglass shape it shows up in that
weird comic strip looking thing that
they refer to as a love story for some
reason and on both characters out that's
around the village most of the meals
that they eat are done at a table that
forms this shape when viewed from
overhead and the pattern that the fire
burns in the final ritual also resembles
this shape
let me know in the comments if you have
any ideas on what it could mean although
this is only the second film by the
director Arie Astor there are a number
of directors trademarks that are already
evident this part of the video will
contain spoilers for his first movie
hereditary family tragedy occurs in both
movies Midsummer opens with the death of
Danny's sister from parents and
hereditary shows the decapitation of the
daughter Charlotte the Incarnation is a
theme in both movies in mid-summer it's
implied that the spirits of the ones are
reincarnated into Maya's baby hereditary
is all about reincarnating this demon
named king primal obviously both movies
center around Colts this next one seems
to be not only an Ari Astor trope but
also in a 20-4 trope and seems to be
turning into a horror genre trope
I'm talking of course about using naked
people and more specifically making old
people for scares not sure how this one
got started I think it may have been it
follows so that's what I noticed about
midsummer and I'm sure there's more that
I missed so if you caught anything then
let me know in the comments if you can't
see the things you missed episode that I
did on hereditary then click the video
on the left and remember to subscribe to
seize these worlds from new Horrors
every week bring the death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]